[Musique]
nous sommes le 27 avril 2010 est
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités émission dédiée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département est invitée aujourd'hui eric
gastineau c'est un président heureux
cinq ans après sa création l'association
on vit à trappes poursuit sa mission
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire elle offre une seconde chance
à ceux éloignés de l'emploi tout en
agissant pour l'environnement et puis le
président de rétina france eric moser
habitants de montigny le bretonneux nous
présentera le travail de son association
très active dans la recherche
ophtalmologique elle dispose de son
propre laboratoire de recherche à orsay
bonsoir à tous les deux et merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation en plateau on
va commencer donc par cet anniversaire
l'anniversaire d'envié attrape eric
gastineau envie déjà c'est un réseau
national
l'idée est simple la rénovation
d'appareils électroménagers par des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi et la
revente de ces équipements à bas prix
l'origine 1984 aujourd'hui il ya
cinquante entreprises de ce type en
france comment se porte la vôtre comment
se porte en vie trappe après cinq années
mais déjà envie trappe c'est une des
plus jeunes effectivement du réseau que
vous évoquez et c'est une structure qui
n'a cessé de grandir et de progresser
tout au long des années donc cinq ans
était effectivement l'occasion de
marquer cette étape de faire un premier
bilan de l'activité de résultats donc
c'est une structure encore jeune avec
les défauts de sa jeunesse mais aussi
plein de promesses pour l'avenir qui a
fait des preuves déjà de deux belles
promesses qu'elle peut porter vous avez
une trentaine de salariés une vingtaine
de personnes qui sont perdants parcours
d'insertion
comment ça fonctionne justement
concrètement qui sont les personnes qui
viennent vous voir combien de temps
elles sont accompagnées comment ça
marche alors les personnes que l'on
recrute en parcours d'insertion et
recrute en cdd pour des cdd de 4 mois
décédé d insertion on peut travailler
avec elle sur une durée maximum de deux
ans
des profils sont très diverses vous avez
des jeunes qui n'ont jamais travaillé
qui éprouvent des difficultés à accéder
au marché du travail des personnes plus
anciennes qui ont eu des accidents de
parcours et qui là aussi ont besoin d'un
coup de pouce pour rebondir et se
retrouver dans l'emploi donc notre rôle
à nous c'est de les accompagner de les
former et de leur donner tous les outils
et la confiance nécessaire pour ensuite
être autonome pour retrouver un travail
alors sorti de l'association on
réapprend à avoir un rythme de travail
avoir un chef un supérieur
avoir un emploi du temps tout ça ça fait
partie des des choses que vous encadrez
au delà même du fait de travailler c'est
l'aspect social la sptr rapport à la
société aussi qu'ils aient développé
exactement ça peut paraître assez assez
basique exprimé comme cela mais c'est
pour certains c'est important de
réapprendre des règles de fonctionnement
d'entreprise le lien collectif
l'appartenance à un projet puisqu'il
travaille les personnes qui viennent
chez nous travaillent pour leurs propres
constructions et leur propre avenir mais
également et travaille à fuir à temps
plein pour le projet collectif de
l'association en vie et pour son
activité économique
quels sont les résultats les personnes
qui sont passés par chez vous depuis
cinq ans est-ce que vous avez des suivis
réguliers savoir ce qu'ils sont devenus
alors on est assez fiers des résultats
qu'on peut avoir à trappes
depuis trois ans on a à peu près 80% des
personnes qui qui partent de chez nous
qui soit par de l'emploi soit sur des
formations qualifiantes donc c'est un
bon résultat
ensuite sur le suivi on a la chance de
garder sur le territoire des personnes
qui reviennent régulièrement nous voir
notamment on a quelques salariés en c1
stars y ait des envies qui travaille
actuellement pour auchan service en
activité ce rappel en cours et qui
viennent régulièrement nous
passer un petit bonjour on les a vus aux
cinq ans à notre anniversaire
ça fait ça fait plaisir de pouvoir les
suivre et de voir comment ils se
construisent aussi professionnellement
familles allemandes ont tous leur
construction aussi social autour du
travail vous êtes limités aujourd'hui en
termes de capacité d'accueil pour ces
personnes en parcours de réinsertion
parce que j'imagine qu'il ya aussi
peut-être beaucoup de demandes et que
vous ne pouvez pas tout satisfaire alors
effectivement on peut pas dire oui à
tout le monde mais on a beaucoup de
demandes non on recrute messieurs marc
en fonction des besoins et et du turn
over dans l'entreprise et on essaye
d'être le plus objectif possible sûr on
va dire seul sur sur les personnes qu'on
accueille en fonction de leur motivation
essentiellement c'est vraiment ça en
fait à l'idée c'est pas leurs
compétences on ne traite pas des gens de
renault sur une compétence sont les
recrutent sur une motivation et on
essaie de construire avec lui ensuite le
projet donc l'idée c'est de grossir pour
accueillir le plus en plus de monde mais
aussi faire du tri qualitatif en termes
d'accompagnement et de pouvoir aussi
parfois se poser un csc un peu le cas au
bout de cinq ans alors on a dix-sept
personnes en contrat d'insertion et
c'est une bonne chose
aujourd'hui il faut faire un travail
qualitatif de formation d'accompagnement
pour qu'ensuite elle puisse encore une
fois retrouvé du travail le plus
facilement possible
on est sur l'aspect social l'aspect
entreprises ya un autre volet aussi
c'est l'aspect environnemental pour
récupérer donc ce matériel qui est
rénové a reçu ensuite remis en vente à
des prix défiant toute concurrence c'est
aussi le but qu'elles sont les
partenariats que vous avez pu tisser
avec les groupes sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
alors vous avez raison c'est l'autre
gros volet enfin il ya trois visions en
fait d'un projet en ville une vision
sociale vision écologique et une vision
économique est évidemment donc sur la
partie environnementale
non depuis cinq ans on a on a rénové
douze mille 500 appareils ce à peu près
600 tonnes de déchets évités c'est 5000
tonnes de déchets collectés au total sur
cette période
on travaille en amont avec des matériels
qui sont mis à disposition par des
entreprises telles que darty
conforama dans des filières qui sont
très organisés très structuré et qui
sont chapeautées par des éco organismes
comme écosystèmes ou écologiques et puis
ensuite sur le redire sur la partie aval
on essaie de développer des partenariats
économiques avec là aussi des
distributeurs classiques des le
communicative comme auchan pas quelles
sont les perspectives de développement
pour pour conclure vous avez pu
développer de nouvelles activités ces
dernières années enfin au fur et à
mesure ces derniers mois plus tôt hélas
ces derniers mois c'est ce qu'on essaie
de faire on essaye on en a une clientèle
qui est essentiellement une clientèle de
particuliers on essaye et on a développé
des accords des partenariats avec des
entreprises donc travailler en bi tube i
comme ça ça nous permet d'une part de
professionnaliser un petit peu plus
notre structure de développer des
passerelles emploi avec nos partenaires
et puis de s'approprier des process
économies de fonctionnement et dégager
de nouvelles ressources
donc c'est ce qu'on a fait avec la
société picard par exemple avec une
petite société d'origine irlandaise qui
passe ou mots dont on entretient les
matériels il vend des jus de fruits qui
fait des jus de fruits et puis on a
d'autres projets de développement avec
la cami par exemple est bien bonne
anniversaire une fois de plus merci mais
après ces cinq ans et on suivra
régulièrement bien évidemment puisqu'on
était déjà venu vous voir plus d'une
fois l'évolution du travail que vous
menez vous restez avec nous on va parler
du travail de l'association rétina à
présent c'est une association et qui se
bat pour la recherche ophtalmologique et
son président est basée à
montigny-le-bretonneux vous résidez à
montigny bonsoir à vous recevoir
vous êtes président de cette association
qui intervient sur tout le territoire
national ou même à l'international aussi
cette invasion à travers le monde entier
quels sont les objectifs pardon de
rétina aujourd'hui alors d'abord retina
est une association nationale de
déficients visuels qui regroupe vingt
mille membres elle est reconnue
d'utilité publique et son objectif
principal effectivement c'est de
financer la recherche
faut savoir qu'en france il ya une
centaine d'associations qui s'occupent
effectivement des malvoyants des non
voyants
mais plus je dirais dans l'aide au
quotidien et nous on s'est vraiment
spécialisés sur
sur la recherche alors pour ce faire
l'association de bord est né en 1984
comme la mondre donc elle a 33 ans
aujourd'hui cette association en fait à
la particularité d'avoir un comité
scientifique national donc qui est
composé d'une vingtaine de chercheurs et
l'objectif donc de ces chercheurs c'est
de valider les projets suite à un appel
d'offres en fait qui est lancé chaque
année en gros on doit aux finances à peu
près un million d'euros de projets
chaque année donc ça représente 13 14 15
projets qui sont valides et donc par ce
comité scientifique et il est
aujourd'hui c'est le premier financier
pour la recherche ophtalmologique le
budget 2 millions de roses vous avez
votre propre laboratoire de recherche
voilà on a effectivement un laboratoire
de recherche qui gérait spécialisé sur
la thérapie génique et cellulaire et qui
travaille donc plus je dirais sur des
excès nope des murs un donc pour
effectivement arriver à des essais
cliniques ça c'est très important pour
nous donc on a notre laboratoire et on
vient de créer une fondation dont elle a
juste un an aujourd'hui
et cette fondation effectivement c'est
toujours pour collecter des fonds pour
continuer à financer la recherche
et ce qui est intéressant aussi ce qui
est important c'est comment collectons
ces fonds et on a effectivement comme
toutes les associations des legs ont
mais on a aussi des manifestations
sportives culturelles
d'ailleurs à montigny le bretonneux la
salle jacques brel en fête accueille
deux concerts chaque année deux concerts
avec une dizaine de corps al-sharq
groupe
on a 200 participants dont on pense
qu'il ya des gens qui doivent se
reconnaître à dire tient effectivement
au mois de mars
nous y étions aussi et on a aussi
effectivement des partenariats avec des
laboratoires pour nous aider
effectivement à financer la recherche
alors on fait partie quand même de d'une
grande structure internationale qui
regroupe 44 pays et on a eu par exemple
en 2014
un congrès international qui à paris en
fête a réuni 1000 participants avec 50
chercheurs venus de du monde entier
puisque on travaille aussi avec l'europe
avait que des chercheurs américains
japonais anglais etc
on va revoir les images de ce congrès
d'ailleurs pendant qu'on parle on les a
aperçus tout à l'heure quels sont les
résultats vous avez pu obtenir parce que
concrètement le but vous l'avez dit
c'est pas accéder au quotidien c'est le
monde devait permettre de guérir ces
différentes maladies alors voilà
l'objectif effectivement c'est de
trouver le traitement ses deux coeurs et
vous c'est que c'est très difficile
parce que la recherche avance
fictivement à grands pas mais alors on a
quand même quelques succès je pense par
exemple on en parlait tout à l'heure de
la dea mais là c'est qu'il ya deux types
de dm est là qui touche d'ailleurs faut
le dire 1.5 millions de personnes en
france
ça représente à peu près une personne
sur trois personnes sur quatre de plus
de 65 ans bon et le traitement par
exemple que l'on a trouvée pour la dm
est là une idée qui touche 20% donc des
patients un traitement qui permet de
ralentir voire même de stopper
l'évolution de la dea mais là ça ne
permet pas de guérir
c'est vrai aujourd'hui mais tout de même
de stopper si vous laissez la forme
humide ce sont des néo vaisseau qui se
forme sur la rétine et l'injection intra
oculaire permet de réduire voire de
diminuer considérablement ses
néovaisseaux et de récupérer finalement
la vue centrale qui avait disparu pour
qu'on comprenne aussi votre combat
j'aimerais juste repréciser votre votre
parcours parce que vous même vous avez
été touchés par ces d'inflation ce
visuel et vous avez dû arrêter votre
activité tout à fait donc c'est là vous
vous êtes dit il faut se battre pour la
recherche qui finalement nous n'avons
peut-être pas assez vite si on se prend
pas en main il est si on ne fait pas les
choses exactement tout à fait alors jugé
travail est d'ailleurs tout à côté
puisque j'étais dans le groupe bouygues
pendant plus de vingt ans et j'ai
terminé ma carrière donc j'étais
directeur des ressources humaines en
charge du campus donc de la formation et
c'est vrai que en 2012
j'étais obligée de cesser mon activité
compte tenu de mon champ visuel en fait
qui avait réduit ses coûts s'est
considérablement et j'ai trouvé cette
cette association et je me suis dit mais
c'est vrai que je pense que ce qui est
important c'est le traitement c'est de
guérir c'est de trouver de la guérison
et notamment séquence est une maladie
héréditaire donc là dans ma famille en
fait plusieurs personnes sont touchées
donc je suis d'autant plus passionné je
dirais est investi dans cette démarche
pour justement trouver un traitement et
quand je parlais tout à l'heure de la
thérapie cellulaire et de la thérapie
génique on y est proche je pense que
dans les quatre cinq années prochaines
on je pense qu'on aura droit sans doute
un traitement pour guérir ces maladies
de rétinite pigmentaire et donc on peut
conclure c'est un message d'espoir à mes
côtés quand on est complètement la
recherche avancée elles avancent bien il
avance bien on renvoie bien évidemment
aux sites internet aussi à votre
association pour en savoir plus sur vos
modes de fonctionnement et aussi pour y
participer puisque associations que ce
soit l'association on vit aussi ou
encore l'association rétina vous
fonctionnez bien évidemment avec les
dons et l'implication des citoyens au
quotidien merci d'être venus également
plateau merci à tous les deux c'est la
fin de cette édition du 7 8 les invités
qui reviendra la semaine prochaine en
raison de ce week end prolongé très bon
week end les replays sont sur notre site
internet
[Musique]